clown around a lot on the set there's BB
gun fights there's yes BB gun fight yeah
not so much in this this one target
practice in this one but ya know so much
like you to fight there the data would
ocean weight you shot what did you shoot
in the absolute hell no new plays bill
striker
those are dangerous I mean DB guns
there's an element of danger they're
protective eyewear yeah but he shot him
in the ass he does good place there's
lots of flesh yeah
so you've literally are they're trying
to shoot a movie this is a big-budget
movie and there's a lot of running
around and you guys they're trying to
get you on the set and you have BB guns
and you're firing at each other yeah the
last one was worse they actually stopped
us in the end because people had like
lumps bleeding out shooting people what
are the coaching ladies KATU complained
that the caution Department felt unsafe
at work so we had to down our weapon
it's perfect it might be because who was
were you locked in your trailer not
coming out because Nicholas was on top
of the bed he obviously dropping the
view and thought he was coming in the
skylight he shot me through the crack of
the door was a brilliant shot at getting
right in the jugular I mean the window
your your actors who are insured you
can't get hurt and that's why we're
insured you're trying to then start the
punching game and then from the punching
game of youth but and oh yeah I'm
necessarily hard you McDowell's I will
tell you as someone who's who's right
here that was hard
I am honest and but it's gone from that
to like a weird slapping game as well so
what's the slapping games games just
[Applause]
laughing game involves alcohol but of
course yes and this it's not really a
game it's just basically people do it
with no care it sounds to me like you're
you're it's quaint that you're calling
it a game yeah
drinking alcohol and hitting each other
is just something people yeah we always
we always called that Saturday night me
for rehab yeah as you said slapping game
and how hard do you how hard do you slap
I'm wearing makeup down this side of my
face because James hit me pretty hard
yesterday and I was bruised this morning
really yeah I wish we had more time this
has been absolutely fantastic
and if we did have more time I'd let you
slap me but we're out of time
oh you can do it go alright
that was the best and worst thing that
ever happened to me
hey thanks for watching be sure to click
subscribe to see even more great Conan
clips you may now return to your pirated
movies and creepy Japanese pornography